well i want to talk about another really
big factor and what's going on today and
what also went down in 2020 and that's
media collusion because we have this
tweet from oliver darcy uh um look hey
man shout out to oliver darcy for
actually putting this out here he said
some news in reliable sources senior
white house and admin officials have
been holding briefings with major
newsrooms over the past week as they try
to reshape economic coverage the white
house not happy with the news's media
coverage of the supply chain and economy
has been working behind the scenes
trying to reshape coverage in its favor
senior white house and admin officials
including nec deputy directors david
kamen and bharat rama rama murti along
with port's envoy john porcari have been
briefing major newsrooms over the past
week a source tells me the officials
have been discussing with newsroom
trends pertaining to job creation
economic growth supply chains and more
the basic argument that has been made
the country's economy is in much better
shape than it was last year i'm told the
conversations have been productive with
anchors and reporters and producers
getting to talk with officials to put it
simply they're having secret meetings
behind your back because they want the
press to change their narrative on the
garbage economy and you're suffering
this is what they did with uh
afghanistan he wanted the afghani
president to tell everyone things were
going just just fine
white houses do white houses do
background briefings to people to make
sure they can understand the
complexities of of issues right and help
the media be smart and when the dresses
that is not what this is
this is the fact that they have now
spent how many trillions of dollars
on bills that they've passed to juice
this economy
and it's dead if you take the printing
machine away from these clowns this
economy is going to implode and they
know it okay that's why they're up there
today with the with mitch mcconnell and
the republicans doing a gimmick to get
relief on the debt ceiling okay now what
darcy's outing them on is that they're
back now because they got to have the
media work with them to sell it to the
american people remember they're talking
on the talk shows all week the media is
not or saki said the media is not doing
you're not doing a good job of selling
our program
now they need a media partner to sell it
okay because every time you see anything
with metrics like the jobs report last
week which was what less than half of
what the jobs were and people can
remember this is with a massive infusion
of cash
they say it's oh different than last
year yeah you had another with three
trillion dollars another what two and a
half or three trillion dollars has been
juiced into the system okay and yes it's
a lot worse than last year you've seen
this before i can't i don't like that
the m1 money supply oh yeah yeah right
there i love it i love it right around
the starts of the uh the pandemic they
they instituted a change in reporting
where they said your savings accounts
are now basically checking accounts
which causes the money supply to explode
by by several hundred percent but what
they and they try and argue they always
say to me tim you don't understand that
huge spike is just a change in reporting
because savings are now and okay well
look at since then look at this this
spike we went from what do we got here
16
583 and that's in what billions i think
it is billions of dollars
and now it's at 20 000 billions of
dollars in the span of what we got we
got from june 2020 until october of 2021
we have jumped 4 000 billion dollars in
the money supply
this is fiat money this is the reason
they have forced you i tell people it's
it's you right now every and i'm not
telling you to buy gold and silver or
platinum and i'm not telling you to buy
crypto but here's what i am telling you
you on your own have better get smart on
your own sit there do your study talk to
people because they're forcing you
they're destroying the us dollar in
front of our eyes and they're destroying
you for generations to come if they get
the spending done the 7 trillion dollars
programmatically that you can't take
back every person in this audience under
45 years old you better start to look
for another store of value than the us
dollar either got to look at precious
metals or you got to have to look at
crypto because they've destroyed it's
their this is the machine the machine
right now is out of control and you can
see look let's let's be let's talk facts
look at this gimmick tonight the one
piece of leverage the deplorables have
is the debt ceiling right they got to
come to you and get 60 votes and kind of
push the debt ceiling that they've got
you've got them by the short and curlies
and so tonight as we sit here they've
got a gimmick up there to do it with 51
votes so they they increase it the
republicans don't don't have to take any
hits for it it can go on they need and
remember they can't sell enough bonds to
the to the japanese into the chinese or
to the insurance companies right they
can't raise taxes taxes all revenues to
the government's around three three and
a half trillion dollars right they need
that huge gap which is a train and a
half dollars a year
in perpetuity
plus all these other crazy programs that
are half baked and they haven't thought
through that comes from printing money
okay and that is on people think it's
free it's not free it's the full faith
and credit
of the united states of america that
would be this audience okay that is on
your shoulders okay and and
that is what's going to destroy us it's
out of control and the uniparty takes
care of themselves that's why you have
wicker up there saying yeah we're
thinking about combat troops and
tactical nuclear weapons the uniparty
the party of davos the wall street the
global world corporations and the guys
they paid in in washington d.c what do
you think happens to property value
well i think right now that's why i
think look with zero interest rates this
is the scam they have interest rates
artificially low near zero the assets
are increased that's where you had the
concentration coming off of the uh
the crash in 2008 the greatest
concentration of wealth because what
they did they took the balance sheet of
the federal reserve from 880 million
dollars to 4.5 trillion infused it with
liquidity the system with liquidity
assets expi
blow up
trump called in 2012 best time to buy
stocks or real estate it's coming right
now the same things happen this is why
we've had this greatest concentration of
wealth ever
since since the ccp virus and it's going
to continue for the as soon as they stop
as soon as they cut the machine off
the stock market will collapse so for
the average person who's listening they
got a mortgage on their house you know
35-year mortgage or a 30-year mortgage
or whatever what does this mean to them
and their and their mortgage well the
third if the 35-year mortgage has been
done recently first off get as long-term
mergers you can get as cheap as you get
now why rates are where they are because
remember by and large outside of your
house which i realize is 90 of your net
worth negative interest rates low
interest rates is an unfair tax on
working class people your checking
account your savings account you get no
juice in it there's no way for you to no
way for you
to to accumulate any capital you're
continually on the treadmill while the
larry thinks the world why do you think
they're going around saying hey you're
not going to own anything you don't need
to anything we'll own it larry fink's
going around they're buying up all the
apartment complexes buying up all the
houses to rent it back to you so on your
income you pay for it and they get the
they get the increase in the asset value
you'll have no privacy you'll own
nothing and you'll be happier more than
ever that's their policy that they've
been pushing and since the beginning of
covid i always said the thing that's
going to hurt people the most is not
this virus but the economic consequences
of these larger moves that are being
made because it's not only the
devaluation of the us dollar it's not
only hyper printing the federal reserve
just giving their friends all of their
money in in the hedge on wall street but
it's also the destruction of the global
supply chain and the global economy
which is being eviscerated right now
right in front of our eyes and there's
no fixing it and it's only going to get
way worse before it gives anybody
greatest concentrations of wealth in
mankind's history was the was the result
of the solution for the financial
collapse brought on by wall street and
and and their guys in washington dc in
2008 right the solutions for that and
what happened with the ccp virus those
are the two greatest concentrations of
wealth now you have a a one percent that
what owns 40 or 50 of the country here's
the thing if we don't start to
restructure this and to get more
capitalist into america and that means
every person is a capitalist every
person gets a piece of the action
this system as we have it now will not
survive it cannot survive because the
only way it survives is they got to keep
printing money and they're bad at the
end of that i just need to point out
because you can't see it on the camera
or those are just listening that every
time luke starts talking and getting
into it steve this likes pointing at him
like this is my anarchist this is my
aunt this is my anarchist now
welcome to the light side
we're gonna we're gonna enlighten you
about government not being involved in
our business lord the system
let's talk about uh well well um
um i guess i guess on this issue what
one thing that's always hard for me to
answer that's why i asked about houses
is you know what regular people have to
be worried about i think the obvious
thing is the price of your groceries you
know so i've gone to um you know i was
at the grocery store recently and i
asked the lady who's doing checkout how
price has been and she's telling me it's
it's insane it's crazy we've got you
know i hear from more and more people uh
talking about how they go to the store
and they're they can't they can't afford
it anymore so this is what happens
you've got people in these big cities
who vote in someone like joe biden
because the media colludes to to to prop
up a narrative to protect him to do
whatever then they don't know what's
going on they're ill-informed for me
i'll tell you what i want
i want regular people to have their own
agency in their own power i want them to
know as much as possible so they make
the right decisions so i don't got to
worry about it you know it's frustrating
you know i'm driving down the street and
i see a guy and he's you know he's
pushing a wheelba a wheelbarrow but he's
backwards he doesn't know what he's
doing and i'm like that's frustrating me
guys spin it around grab it by the
handlebars your life will be a lot
easier then i don't got to worry about
you screwing something up for everybody
else but what's happening with the media
the things that oliver darcy points out
is that regular people are confused and
wrong they thought trump was the problem
joe biden the bite administration the
remnants of obama 3. 2.0 or whatever
that is the problem it was the problem i
recognized it then and we're seeing it
now i want to take this inflation thing
let's let's use this as an object lesson
on their smugness and arrogance and i
want to tie it back to what he just said
we now have a remember
when guys like peter navarro and steve
cortez on the war room every day and
we're the first ones to call the
pandemic back in in january 2020 which
shifts the show those guys came on on
the day that biden took office i said
hey we're you look at this guy's
policies we're going to be heading into
1970 stagflation which is slow growth
and inflation they're the first guys to
start talking about and and and uh
cortez is a guy in the pits is a traitor
and and uh navarro is a phd from
harvard's economics department top in
the country right and i know guys laugh
at him but he's a damn good economist
they said this is not gonna be
transitory because now you have the
double whammy they've juiced the system
and they even sit there larry some of
the guys said we should have never done
that interim we should have never done
that last 1.9 trillion that we did that
biting those guys passed in the spring
we shouldn't have done that so now you
have the worst of both worlds you have
what is called uh demand poll right and
cost push because of the broken supply
chains and the structural problems that
navarres has never been dealt with from
the ccp virus and particularly because
in china so now you have a double whammy
that's not transitory it's baked in it's
six eight ten percent right and that
think about it with wages increasing
just at two to three percent in
inflation at six to eight percent that's
a five to six percent absolute tax on
working-class people they're getting
eviscerated right now and and remember
ron claim the chief of staff of the
white house 90 days ago said these are
high-class problems right these are
high-class problems right i saw that
from the progressive left said the same
thing cnn said inflation is good for
they try to sell this it's great for
rich people
let's go to darcy's thing this that
article right there is brittany brought
that up that is the single best example
from oliver darcy's own network if you
look at that article it's a joke they
came out the other day and said hey what
nobody's getting here in the messaging
is that inflation's actually good for
the poor and bad for the wealthy did you
see the i mean it's that that's insane
but this is this is they don't respect
working-class people enough to have the
common decency to sit there and go hey
here's where we are here's what we're
trying to accomplish here's what it's
going to be they just want to continue
to brow beat you over there with
information war to make it seem like
it's your fault well that's because
they're robbing and stealing them
there's an old viral uh old snl skit
that's been going viral and i think it's
dan aykroyd who says you know during i
think it was during carter hey
inflation's a good thing don't you want
to own a 5 000 suit wouldn't you like to
own a 500 000 car i know i would
smoke a 50 cigar that's actually kind of
a question i have for you steve maybe
you can answer maybe you can't um if you
have a hundred thousand dollar house the
economy gets inflated by 50 the house
naturally is worth 150 000 now just due
to account inflation at what point if
you keep inflating the economy does the
house become worth zero or does the the
house's value no longer it's not worth
100 million anymore like at what point
do you inflate more money by the value
at the at the point where you can't
people can't afford to finance it right
you're gonna have an asset bubble this
is okay
one of the things that president trump
did let's go back to 2008 which you know
from the occupy movement when um when uh
obama came in
and they had the balance sheet was 880
billion dollars and his guy said let's
inflate the balance sheet the fed just
put we'll just force cash into the
system to save the system to prop up to
prop up assets okay you had an asset
bubble that was increasing when trump
came in in his first two years of office
with a three percent growth he actually
took a trillion dollars off the balance
sheet of the federal reserve he actually
shrunk it wasn't quantitative easing it
was kind of
quantitative tightening okay and that's
one thing he never gets credit for those
kind of growth rates
low inflation with not unjuicing the
system was an act of heroism now
powell when powell came in and mnuchin
and these other guys we started to put
it back on you've got you know the
balance sheet of the fed i think is 6
train or 7 train today because of what
the ccp rises besides that's that's over
and above what the national debt is so
my point is wall street always wants to
inflate their way out of here the
problem is you get an asset bubble and
then people can't afford it and in the
real economy can't keep up you can't
they don't have people that have jobs
and can start to afford your hundred
thousand dollar house that's now a
million dollar house so you're kind of
getting into a vicious circle and this
is what people are probably this is the
problem people have right now
the um
zero hedge has a great article i think
it's from birch gold um the guy's name
brandon smith i think it is is on zero
hedge today it talks about the coming
collapse right and the coming collapse
is when they gotta stop printing money
because in printing money remember it's
on the backs of working-class people
you're gonna you or your kids are
eventually gonna pay this off because
they ain't paying it off right so that
that's why it's gotta be
certain things go up and particularly
like housing and some of your assets
your asset value will go up now it's
about can you get priced out of can kids
today because you have no capital you
have no ability to accumulate capital
how do you get the down payment or you
don't have a great enough job to
actually make the mortgage payment
you're paying for it already with the
dollar of being in the value thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00
pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time